i wanted to let you all know that i will
be throwing the annual parks department
employee appreciation barbecue
you're gonna throw the leslie knope
employment enjoyment summerslam grill
jam fun splosion
that's right you are gonna oversee the
popsicle eating contest the slip and
slide-a-thon the watermelon carving the
gazpacho
and star in a one-woman show about parks
rules and regulations
parks and dolls i got your park right
here
its name is ramsett park and its gates
i am not doing any of that which is the
point
every summer leslie throws a barbecue to
thank the parks and maintenance staff
it's horrifying barbecues should be
about one thing
good shared meat there will be no froofy
desserts
there will be no giant soap bubble guns
there will be
no adult men in costumes and most of all
there will be no vegetables
well ryan can we at least have corn on
the cob
no you ever tried a turkey burger is
that a fried turkey leg
inside a grilled hamburger if so yes
delicious
a turkey burger you take lean ground
turkey meat you make that into a burger
instead of red meat
why would anyone do that to themselves
ah
nirvana hey guys amber annie bill
johnny no i don't plan to buy anything
here
i buy my burger ingredients at food and
stuff
a discount food outlet equidistant from
my home and my work
i came here for the same reason people
go to the zoo
look at that thing
nature is amazing would you like to
sample our vegan bacon
100 meatless yes please
another please
sir is there a problem i'm just making
sure no one ever has to eat this
i i don't think i can give you any more
i want one
i offered ron a job last month and he
turned me down
and it literally broke my heart but
now i see that this is truly where he
belongs
way to me ron you're really getting it
done man
he can't hear me okay let's begin the
barbecue
oh hey little guy hey what are you doing
oh
no everyone meet your meat
oh oh no why are you doing this to us
well in my opinion not enough people
have looked their dinner in the eyes and
considered the circle of life
this is your dinner his name is tom
bern seriously no i understand that it's
hilarious but that is his given
christian name
tom is very smart and incredibly loyal
he's basically a dog
a dog we're going to cook chew and
swallow dude there's kids around here
good point which one of you youngsters
wants to help me drain the blood from
this animal
if you do a good job i'll give you the
bladder you can blow it up for a fun
play ball
hey ron you're not gonna slaughter that
pig here are you
not to worry i have a permit
this just says i can do what i want i am
the director of the parks department
and this is a park it's not a parks
thing it's against like three laws and
a dozen health codes
fine barbecue is postponed until i can
go pick up some meat from the food and
stuff
let's go tom no pig tom
[Music]
i love food and stuff it's where i buy
all of my food
and most of my stuff
hey can i get these how much are there
two bucks a piece
good deal
anything else nope just the crows and
the beef
i humbly place before you my east meets
west patented traeger turkey burger
an asian fusion burger made with willow
farms organic turkey
a toasted tilegio cheese crisp papaya
chutney black truffle aioli
and micro greens on a gluten-free
brioche bun
enjoy this tastes as delicious as
beyonce smells
i'm guessing what is this in here
saffron
wow somebody's got a sharp palate i love
the umami flavor
stop being so pretentious kyle sorry
here's mine it's a hamburger made out of
meat
on a bun with nothing add ketchup if you
want
i couldn't care less
ron i'm so disappointed i thought that
you and i were going to have a real
challenge
never mind this is better way better
kyle sorry andy ron's is better damn it
kyle
hmm oh my god so much better it's crazy
turkey can never beat cow chris sorry
i don't understand i i i've tinkered
with this recipe for years
granted it's been a long time since i've
had hamburger
this is better the commissary will
continue to serve
horrifying artery-clogging hamburger
[Applause]
oh my god food food yes i am returned
no not so fast shirley i just have to
thaw the meat
season it and grill it up so it's gonna
be a few hours oh no
ron my tummy's rumbling it's scary
tommy's got the tom roams ron chris
trager feelings update
i'm now feeling that your guests are
getting a little antsy
fine i'll skip a few steps and speed
things up there you go is there at least
something to drink
there's beer in the cooler what about
for the children you can get water from
that water fountain and use it to water
down the beer
why don't just give the kids water i
suppose you could do that
now would everyone please back off and
just let me cook in peace
these people are soft they're grilled
virgins
but by the time this day is over they'll
have been taken by the grill
and delicately and tenderly shown the
ways of flavorful meat love
the first time is so beautiful ron
can i have a burger i'm hungry for the
last time no burgers yet
i've got ribs and i've got beef cheek
ron where are my vegan soy patties
i gave them to the kids they love them
they're skipping them across the pond
donna i got to go to the boys room can i
have a ride in your car absolutely not
this barbecue stinks
i'm saying it it stinks do you have any
plates or anything i mean how are we
supposed to eat these rumps ron if no
one takes me to the bathroom i'm just
gonna have to go in the trees
all right forget it
you have ruined a perfectly good
barbecue with your demands
and chatter enjoy the rest of your
evening
get in here now
your work is appreciated eat some corn
thanks ron thank you ryan thanks ron
also
here's tom ah
actually smells really delicious it
really does
give me some of tommy's ribs sorry tom
oh my gosh
you